I think that the Vegas the there's
there's I have lots of like ticks you
know that I think that and lots of
things that bug me about I sort of think
about it it's kind of like fashion you
know a song has to feel good when you're
singing it has to feel like you know
somebody will put on a suit and you know
you have people that you know who put on
clothes and they look effortlessly good
in them and it's like there was no work
and and whether or not that's the case
the fact is that you have to feel
comfortable singing what you're singing
and and so some things that make me
uncomfortable are rhymes that seem a
little too obvious rhymes that seem a
little too rhymes that are overused girl
world girl world syndrome knife strife
shelf myself you know I stay away from
all those I like I don't like
autobiographical songs I don't think
that there and I don't like
autobiographical singing I don't want to
think about the person who's singing the
song on stage like I feel like a song is
your chance to like like a short story
or or anything is a chance to like a you
know live inside a character that's kind
of that's been given to you you're being
given this character and then you can
you can live inside it not a chance to
see inside somebody else's private life
you know I just don't like that I don't
think it leads to very original song
writing you know those those are some
things that those are some things that
that I that bug me but I'm good songs
are you know they're they're just
they're there things that you can sing
in the car on the way home without a
guitar that you can play yourself and
learn how to do you know